[Music]
all right
the sound seems to be on hello everyone
I'm Nicola and I'm so sorry hello
first things first take advantage of the
Dory Q&A feature or indoor cloud next
app to ask questions that you might have
during the session and to vote for the
questions that sounds interesting to you
and in the end it will take a little bit
of time to answer some of the questions
on the top so please raise your hands
how many of you run workloads on
multiple virtual machines the majority
of people and how many of you do any
kind of batch computation on multiple
machines also quite a few and how many
of you have at least one virtual machine
on compute engine pretty much most of
the people awesome so let's see how it
works when you deploy a new application
you would probably start with one
machine the purification to this machine
test it run it and you might have a few
users this setup is quite easy to manage
manually or maybe not that easy how do
you know what machine type to pick how
much CPU or memory do you need you
probably could take the same machine
size as you use in your own print data
center before but compute engine allows
you find finding granular configuration
of how many CPU cores or how much memory
you can pick there is a good chance that
there is a machine type that is just as
well fit for your workload but is
smaller and cheaper how do you know that
you don't waste money and once your
workload grows and you get more users
you will need multiple machines to run
it this is where all kinds of problems
might start and it is not no longer
feasible to manage this type of setup
manually
let's look at what kind of problems
those could be first of all your
application might stop responding or
crash some of the users might experience
interruptions or latencies in your
service
another problem is in the rare event a
cold zone might fail and if you have
deployed all your machines in a single
zone your customers might experience
complete outage this is not something
that you want to experience or you load
my spike and land on insufficient number
of VMs and the extra customers that you
have again might experience longer
latency or don't be served at all
something you don't want to happen or
maybe you have provisioned enough of the
machines to serve even your highest
peaks but then what when we can we can't
comes for example and your users drops
you don't want to overpay for all those
extra machines that are sitting idle and
on top of all of that you will probably
continuously improve your application
and run all kinds of updates security
patches new features how do you roll out
the updates safely and avoid the
disruption in case of a bad update for
users when any of these problems happen
you don't want to get paged especially
in the middle of the night because when
coming to cloud you expect your
infrastructure to run flawlessly and the
good news is that manages groups on
compute engine allows you to take care
of these problems automatically and
build you highly available scalable
applications where you can roll out
updates automatically and safely and
also pick the optimal size of the
machines for your work laws so that you
can have a peace of mind knowing that
your application is taken care of in
today's session we will look how to
deploy an application to a managed
instance group will build a stateless
load-balanced application and we will
also look into how to apply VM
right-sizing recommendations to those
machines and if you're already familiar
with some of this concept will have Pro
tips for you so let's start with the
application deployment you likely have
some kind of CI CG pipeline which
results in an artifact you could package
your application in container image or
perhaps pre-baked it together with
all of the dependencies on the boot disk
image or maybe write a startup script on
top of a plain vanilla operating system
so that it loads and boots your
application on VM start any of these
approaches work with what we are going
to talk about today but for the sake of
example let's pick container image
deploying container image is easy on
compute engine and takes only two steps
you create an instance just as you would
any regular VM you click the checkbox
that you want to deploy container
specify which container to run and some
of the parameters let's say start a
restart policy or you could pass some
environment variables to your container
and what happens is that our compute
engine will create virtual machine based
on the container optimized operating
system image which already has docker
and containers startup agent
pre-installed and it will boot your
container on vm start automatically you
don't need to write any startup screen
and on top of that whenever you create a
new machine you could use the latest
version of the container image with all
of the updates and security patches that
are managed by Google so if one machine
is not enough you can also deploy your
application to multiple machines in a
managed instance group so the the way
you do it is that you create instance
template in exactly the same way as it's
a reversal machine and then instance
template is like a recipe for creating
the machine that managing such groups
uses to create your VMs and if your
application is load balanced you can add
your instance group as a back-end
service to a load balancer that's it so
let's see how it works
ok so first we need to create an
instance template before the
presentation I've uploaded the container
to the container registry you can upload
it using dr. fouch command or just
manually if you want so let's copy the
full repository name now let's create an
instance template
[Music]
let's put the URL and also let's allow
HDB traffic and to the container because
we have a simple web server application
running in this container so we can
verify that that it's accepting drugs so
right now we have to wait for your
seconds for the template to be created
and once it's done we can start and
create a managed instance group using
this this template so let's call it
tainer we can deploy it in any zone you
want you can turn on auto scaling for
now you can do this later
and that's create so right now what is
happening is Google compute engine is
creating manage instance group that will
manage all your instances within this
within sounds and right now you see that
it's already created and you can see
that there is a new VM that it's
starting so once it's being created we
can verify what is happening inside so
let's go to the VM let's go to the
console and you can see the all the
commands that are running during the
varium so it's being set up the IP is
being applied to the VM so ok we can
also see right there ok let's refresh so
what is happening in the background that
our VM is pulling the container you can
see it right here it's putting the
container from the registry it's
starting and once it started it will
boot up and we can verify that it's
working by entering the IP address in
the URL and we can see that it's up and
running and serving our web application
within like few minutes back to you
Michael
Thanks can you get back to the slides me
thank you yeah so we have deployed a
simple stateless application to an
instance group but now how do we make it
highly available and scalable but let's
first talk about what a stateless
application is a good example of it
would be for example a front-end of a
web store you want it to be highly
available so that your customers don't
get HTTP 500 during checkout process and
you want it to be scalable so that you
can get all the business you can even
during the spikes such as on Black
Friday and stateless VMs are like a herd
of sheep you care only about how many of
you have you can easily replace one with
another and the machines work exactly
the same way and they don't carry any
State on them so let's go back to the
problems that might happen whatever
application stops responding or crashes
I see you have a question there could
you put it on a door and then we'll
address it in the end so if the
application stop stop so spawning or
crashes how to healing would help to
take care of that it will automatically
recreate the instances detect that they
have it will detect that they have
failed and automatically recreate them
to keep them in service so that your
customers can be served again
configuring out the healing is easy all
you need to do is to create a health
check and attach it to the managed
insular group and the way the health
checking works is that it pings your
application on a regular basis in a
specified port and protocol as HTTP 80
on a path that you show and it will
expect HTTP 200 response that everything
is okay within a predefined latency that
you can configure and if the health
check fails multiple times in a row and
again you can configure how many times
this is let's say two failures then
instance is deemed unhealthy and out
Hindle healing will kick in to recreate
it from the instance template with the
well tested configure
and health checking works for both HTTP
HTTPS protocols as well as TCP and SSL
what's important to note is that you can
create exactly the same health checks
for load balancing purposes and load
balancer users health checks differently
than managed instance groups when the VM
is marked as unhealthy load balancer
does not spend new traffic to the
machine and will send it to the other
machines that are still healthy at the
same time managing this group will
recreate a machine that is unhealthy to
bring back in service these are very
different actions and for that reason we
highly recommend you to create different
health checks for load balancer and for
managed instance group and make it
health check more aggressive for a load
balancer more aggressive meaning shorter
check intervals expect lower response
latency and maybe lower number of failed
health checks to actually market on
healthy this is important because
imagine the situation when you have a
machine that is serving its full
capacity so it cannot really receive
more traffic and will produce latencies
you want a load balancer to redirect
this traffic to other machines at the
same time the machine is perfectly
healthy is serving existing connections
so you don't want the outer healer to
kick in and recreate it so to make sure
that in such situation your machine is
not recreated you should give out the
healer a little bit more time for the
machine to recover and start serving
again or if it's really unhealthy for a
longer period only then we created
that's why you need two health checks
another pro tip is that when you can
figure out the healing make sure you set
an initial delay to a higher value than
it takes for your machine to start
during the initial delay outer healing
will not touch and healthy machines to
give enough time for the application to
boot of course while VM is booting it
will be unhealthy because your
application is not yet serving so if you
set initial delay to longer than it
takes to serve you will make for the
application to start serving it will
make sure that out of here even all it
will only recreate a machine when it
is really unhealthy and not because it's
still booting so let's see how other
healing works all right so we have an
instance group with three VMs up and
running all of the VMS are running the
same web application this is a simple
Python script it has a few features one
of the features is reporting the health
status of an application so if we click
here you can verify that our application
is up and running it's serving HTTP 200
response so it's basically saying to the
manage instances yes I'm okay I can
accept traffic and I can serve traffic
so what I did is I created a simple
method that will just start reporting on
how he status so what it means is that
once I opened the same view well it's
basically saying I'm sorry I've crashed
I will not accept any I should not
accept any connections right now so it's
telling manage instance group that this
VM is not responding the application is
not running so it should be recreate
let's go here
it usually takes a minute or two for the
manage instance group tool to notice it
so let's go and look how they I mean how
the health check is configured so we've
set up the health check out the healing
so let's go to the health checks out of
healing so we can see that it's looking
at the path slash health so it's the
same that I've used previously is using
the HTTP protocol on port 80 it's
pinging the application every five
seconds and it's waiting - for two
consecutive failures to notice that it's
unhealthy let's go back to our manage
instance group out of healing and you
can see that management group detected
that a application crashed and that the
VM should be recreated and it's already
recreating so after a minute it will be
up and running and your traffic and your
VMs will accept traffic and it's
everything will be fine can you switch
back to the slides peace alright
so we have just protected our
application against failure on a single
machine but what if there is a more rare
event when there is a miss configuration
or something happens and the whole zone
is out
Auto hilly will not help you with that
because even if it tries to recreate the
machines the problem is not on the
machine it's on the zonal level so in
order to protect your workload against
that you can deploy your machines to
multiple zones in the region using
regional managed instance groups and in
this example the way it works that even
if a single zone fails the load balancer
will send traffic to the other zones
where the machines are still available
and your customers will still be served
it's worth noting that on this picture
is all that you lose one third of your
capacity so let's say if you need nine
VMs to serve all of your traffic if it's
on fails you get on the six so if you
want to really have enough capacity to
even in case of us on Kayla failure to
serve all of your users you should
provision extra VMs so that 2/3 of it of
the total number is enough to serve the
traffic so in this example for example
if you deploy let's say six extra VMs
even if it singles on fails you still
have ten VMs which is more than enough
to cover your requirement of nine and
the way to calculate how many extra VM
to provision is easy you just delete
divide the number of total VM that you
need to serve your workload by the
number of the remaining serving zones so
for example if you deploy your group to
three zones you need to provision 50%
extra machines so that even in case of
zone failure you have enough machines to
serve all of your traffic so let's see
how this works okay so we have another
managed instance group this time that
it's it's deployed and three different
zones you can verify it here that it's
deployed and you were central 1b C and F
and in the end in each zone we have
instances that are running we've also
configured a load balancer that will
direct traffic to all of the instances
let's go open it up and you can see that
on each refresh it should work one more
time yeah
on each refresh we get a VM that is
serving from a from a from a different
zone so what I did is I wrote a simple
script that will just scrub the webpage
from there from each of the instance get
a zone that the instance is running in
and do a loop printer printers on the
screen so you can see that right now we
have instances serving from all of the
zones so how to do a test on the how to
test if they're zone files so I cannot
bring the whole zone down obviously but
I can what I can do is I can simulate it
by disabling health checks like sorry
not disabling like start making our VMs
report unhealthy from particular zone so
let's do it
save all your sensual one all right so
what I did as I told you right now VMs
from zone app or are starting to report
that are unhealthy
so load balancer will notice it in a
matter of seconds and will stop
directing traffic you can already see
that we are serving traffic only from
zone B and C so that's also disabled
zombie
more seconds all right you can see that
Lola's notice it and right now we are
serving only from zone C so let's bring
back all the zones back up alright so
all the VMS are reporting start was the
healthy soul on balazar pings
each of the VM notice said that it's
starting upon healthy and it's except
except traffic and will start directing
the traffic back to Dawn's VM see you
already see that zombie is up and
running and zone F will be available in
a matter of seconds can we get back to
the side piece alright so now we have a
highly available application we've
protected it against application failure
and it's in dual machines and also
against a more rare event of a whole
zonal failure but how about the problems
when a load spikes or when you have a
lot going down and excess VMs that you
don't want to pay for it auto scaling
helps you with that it maintains the
group size tailored to the current load
that your service experiences
configuring auto scaling is easy you set
up the load metric on which you want to
scale a very popular one is a CPU or a
CPU usage for example you set the target
load let's say 60% you can also specify
minimum and maximum number of VMs that
autoscaler should not exceed minimum is
useful if you want to have like the
minimum capacity that you always want to
be running and maximum is to essentially
cap your budget against scale up if you
don't want to overspend and also you
need to specify a cooldown period a cool
down during the cooldown period it
starts when the VM boots
and expires after the number of seconds
you specify autoscaler ignores the
signal from this machine this is because
on vm boot the signal might not reflect
the actual real-life load as many of the
boot processes can utilize CPUs more
than usual so make sure you configure
cooldown period to a higher values and
the VM takes to boot so that your
autoscaler takes only the signal that
represents the actual load and hence
makes more accurate scaling decisions so
let's see how to scaling works let's say
you have three overloaded machines and
the target load of 60% how to scale you
will notice that it's way above the
average load is way above the target and
will create two more machines to bring
the average load back to the target now
if the load goes down over time
autoscaler will notice again that the
average is now significantly lower than
the target and will remove the extra
machines to bring it back to the target
that's that's how it works
in a nutshell and pro tip is that if you
want to make sure that your workload
scales up really fast you should use a
lower target CPU load like if we look at
the example here if you have three
overloaded machines of let's say a to
70% and 90% utilization if you set the
target load of 60% autoscaler will scale
the group size to four machines and if
you set a target lower to lower value
like say 40% it will get six machines
which is a faster scale-up and one more
tip if you use auto scaling with
regional management such groups the same
approach applies as for fixed size
groups we shall know that was killed
make sure that you set a maximum number
of instances to a higher value that is
needed to serve your load so that even
if a hold on failure happens autoscaler
has enough room to scale up in the other
zones the formula of calculating how
much extra to set for the maximum is the
same as for the fixed size make the only
difference is
that in the fixed-sized group you will
have this machines always running where
isn't a skilled group you don't have to
pay for them this is only a theoretical
maximum that you allow your autoscaler
to reach so let's look at how to scale
in in practice okay so we have one VM
that is running the same web server
application so I told you that this web
server has a few different features so
one was reporting heavy on how he
started the second one is making the
high load on the CPU so what it does in
the background is just multiplying two
random numbers in a local attorney and
it delay so it's basically making the
CPU utilized being utilized in 100%
let's look how our auto scaling is
configured so we are looking at the CPU
usage and we want to have our management
stance groups scaled to be below 50% on
average use it of all on all the VMS
minimum number census is one that's why
you saw one instance up and running and
we have maximum number of instances set
to five and cooldown period set to
thirty seconds which means that auto
scale error will not look at the CPU
utilization for the effort for the first
30 seconds our application is quite
small it sorts quite fast so but if you
have very high intensive workload for
example creating the cache or something
else you can put a bigger number here so
let's go back okay you can already see
that can we get back to the do this to
the screen okay you can already
see that autoscaler notice said that
this first VM was over utilized and
started to put up additional VMs if the
o CMS will be also utilized in over 50%
autoscaler will schedule another vm
creations and bring it up to number 5
thank you alright so now we have a
highly available auto scaled application
but how about updates how do you roll
out the updates automatically but also
protect your customers against bad
pushes which sometimes happens how to
updater allows you to do just that and
but before we go into how you configure
it let's think about what an update is
in the beginning you have a instance
group in an old version at the end you
want to have it in the new version and
update is a journey of how you get from
the old version to a new one as it takes
multiple steps and you can configure the
journey with the following parameters
first you can set up how many machines
do you want to update maybe you want
update the whole group if this is an
urgent fix maybe you want to do a
cannery update and update on the part of
it so let's say roll out to half of the
group to see how it works before
proceeding second parameter is how many
machines do you update at the same time
as the machines need to be recreated
from a new instance template for an
update so this is your disruption budget
third parameter is how many extra VMS
any new version to add temporarily for
the update this is useful if you don't
want to take any of the old machines
down but keep them in service and
instead create the new machines in new
versions in the new version wait until
they start serving in only the Entei
ground the old ones finally you can
specify the minimum wait time which is
after the machines have been updated how
long to wait before proceeding to the
next batch in the rolling updates
you can also use recreate or restart
actions for an update recreate is when
you recreate it from the new instance
template where star is useful when you
use an agent inside a machine for an
update and you need to restart to
actuate that update with the same
rollout logic as above and finally you
can make an update our proactive which
means that it will do the role in update
automatically or opportunistic which
means that it will only create new
machines when they are needed for
example when scaling up and it will only
delete the old machines when also it's
needed for example if you resize the
group down and you can have even more
fine-grained control over update for
example which specific machines to
update when in which order by setting
the update for opportunistic changing
the instance template in the group and
then just recreating the machines that
you wants to update manually and on
machine recreation they will pick up the
new instance template and you will get a
new version this way you can be in the
full control of the rollout if you don't
want an update to be automatic so let's
look at some of the common scenarios
rolling update is is the first one so
imagine you have a quick fix that you
need to roll out to the whole group so
you set a new template 200 percent
However
to stay on the safe side and not to
disrupt the service too much you said
that the rollout say 3 machines at a
time and if the update is good
updater will proceed with the next 3
machines if it's bad it or bad means it
doesn't pass the health checks their
beta will stop and then you can come and
check out what's happening and the back
or maybe make a rollback decision but if
everything is going well the updater
will take 3 machines by 3 machines until
the whole group is updated and it will
only proceed to the next batch of 3 once
the previous three have passed the
health checks another very common
scenario is canary update so imagine you
have a webstore and you roll out an
update that is supposed to increase
conversion to purchases
of course you're not gonna roll out it
to the whole group right away you
probably wants to cannery it let's say
to 30% and wait for a while maybe a week
maybe a month to collect enough data to
prove that the conversion is indeed
improved and roll it forward if that's
the case all roll back if it didn't
happen so let's have a look okay so
let's do both things at the same time
both things what McCullough said so
let's do a cannery update in a rolling
fashion so we have four VMs all of these
are created from the instance template
one before I will start there all our
process I need to tell you a few words
about this application it's a simple
application that monitors the internal
status of the VM so it will show you
when the VM will start creating when
it's going to be deleted when it's
restarting recreating it will and it
will also show you the version of the
template that it's used to create it so
you can see that we have four
application of our VMs running from
instance template one okay so now let's
initiate the update let's say we want to
have half of our fleet serving from new
version of the application and we'll
also want to spin up one the one new VM
at a time so what it means that will not
exceed the number 5 of VMs that are
running at the same time all right ok
you can see right now that the new VM is
being created and it usually takes about
30 to 45 seconds for the process to be
completed so we need to we need to wait
a bit
once this vm is up and running and
manage instant verify that it's it's
created successfully one of the other
VMs that were created
using the person instance template
version 1 will be deleted 1 this VM the
deletion the deletion process will be
completed will spin up additional VMs
additional one VM so you will see
another bar with green color and the
process continues so right now you can
see that the instance is created it's
created from the version template tool
so we have a new application new version
application running on the VM and once
the process completed the old vm one of
the old VMs was starting to be deleted
and as I said the process will continue
once half of the fleet will be served
from the new version of the applications
makalah yeah and what's great to note is
that when you do a cannery update let's
say to half of the create a fleet even
if the group is out of scaled it will
automatically maintain this ratio for
you if you specify percentage but you
can also specify a fixed number of VMS
and cannery one or two or three VMs as
you wish so another interesting scenario
that is worth looking at is if you have
a highly available workload that you
really don't want to disrupt at all but
you want to roll out update as quickly
as possible
you can set a new template to hundred
percent so you want to update the whole
group but you set max unavailable to
zero so that none of the old serving VMs
is touched and instead max search to a
hundred percent so what's gonna happen
is that the group will create a hundred
percent more VMs in a new version wait
until those VMs pass the health checks
and only then remove the old version so
this way you get finally available
update but which is fast at the same
time so how does updater coordinate with
the other automation services let's say
updater and outer Healy
you have specified that your disruption
budget is two so you can update two
machines at a time take them out of
service and updater successfully did
that now as the updater is about to get
to the next batch one of the old
machines fails out
killing will detect that and we'll start
recreating it but will updater take down
two more machines or one for an update
the good news is that a bidder is aware
of the disruption and will respect your
configuration of marks and available to
and will take only one extra machines
down for an update so that your workload
is still serving at the capacity that
you can tolerate and in the end the one
machine gets updated and another one
gets out to healed how about updater in
auto scaling let's say updater recreates
two machines from the new instance
template and of course while these
machines are being recreated the
remaining VMs will get a bit more
traffic and the average CPU load will
spike will autoscaler create extra
machines the answer is no autoscaler is
aware that the machines that are being
updated will be back up and running soon
so it will keep the group size at the
same value and once the machine a back
the machines are back it will be serving
again
how about updater and regional
management says group updater will
update the machines evenly across the
zones to spread the risk and once the
new machines are up and running it will
also remove the old machines evenly
across the zones again to spread the
risk for you for high availability
finally let's have a look at how data
works with a load balancer so before
taking and recreated a machine for an
update the machine will first stop
receiving new traffic then it will wait
for a connection draining time out to
drain the active sessions you can
configure it in your load balancer
configuration and only once the sessions
are drained updated with the creating
interest from the new template wait
until it becomes healthy and after that
the new machine will start serving
traffic so the update is really very
graceful and won't interrupt any of the
existing connections so there we have it
manage instance groups allow you to
build
highly available scalable applications
that are easy to update automatically
and will take care of application
failure with outer healing will protect
your application against zonal failure
by distributing machines across multiple
zones will also tailor group size to the
variable load without scaling and also
protect the updates from unhealthy
versions but if the machines are healthy
roll it out automatically so that you
can have a peace of mind and focus on
your more important tasks knowing that
your workload is taken care of now let's
have a look at the right size in your
machines we've talked about that it's
not very easy to pick up the right shade
for a machine of course the shape that
you have used back in your on-prem data
center will work but there are many more
potentially possible combinations of CPU
cores and memory that are available on
compute engine so how do you know that
you don't overpay the good news is that
compute engine observes utilization of
the CPU and memory in your machines over
the eight date period which is good if
you work what has a weekly load patterns
or more or less persistent or load over
time and we recommend the optimal size
for your machine if it thinks that the
current size is not optimal either for
individual machines or for VMs in the
machines herbs that are not Auto scaled
horizontally and recommendation can be
either save money if your machine is too
big or if it consistently sees that the
CPU utilization for example is very high
it might suggest you to get a bigger
machine to improve performance of your
workload and what's great is that we
have the recommendations API already
available in alpha which allows you to
get all of the recommendations from your
projects programmatically via restful
api and then with the data you can
aggregate triage prioritize the
recommendation as it makes sense for
your organization build dashboards
reports for your teams visual life
savings and whatnot to help you manage
the costs of your deployments and one
more product is that if you want more
accurate recommendations use stackdriver
monitoring agent on your machines as it
has a better visibility into utilization
inside the machine and as a result will
increase quality of the recommendations
for you so let's have a look all right
we have five different instances so
let's imagine that you have a virtual
machine on your own data center and you
move it to the GCP to Google Cloud using
the exact same size so for example we
have a machine that lets that has four
CPU cores and 15 gigabytes of of memory
but what happens if your application
does not use this this CPU power and
memory will detect it and after one day
we'll give you the recommendation to
size it down to save some money so
resizing the VM is very simple you just
click on the resize you can customize
the VM size for example if you know that
your application is will not even use
two CPUs as we recommended you can even
scale it down to one CPU you click apply
so now what happens is we will
automatically stop the VM change the VMS
shape and start it up without you having
to do anything else well this is the one
type of recommendation so it's basically
telling you size down to save some mine
what what if you've created a VM you've
started the application and right now
the application is very high CPU
intensive for example you have this web
server application that is doing some or
at some part for clothes that are doing
the computations again we detected it
you can we can verify that there is a
process that it's utilizing 100 of the
of the CPU all the time so we detected
it and we are saying basically you
or instances are underutilized and you
should be you should scale it scaled up
and you can apply the same
recommendation and the same way so click
resize change the number of CPUs or or
Ram and be good this same thing works
for managed instance groups so you can
you can see that right now we have a
managed instance group with two
instances and again they have low memory
usage low CPU utilization so you can
make it you can change the instance
template to the smaller one and save
some money each month ok so I will now
show you how to quickly use the use the
API so this is a simple simple one-line
code using curl that will just query the
recommendations and will basically get
the same the same information that you
have seen on the on the screen so for
example here we can see that some
information about about the zone and
that will say 74 US dollars if you apply
these recommendations and using it you
can build as McCulloch said a simple
dashboard that will aggregate all
information from all the VMS in your
project from all the projects that are
created by you for example some some and
give you the total savings per month
from all the recommendations that you
saw can you get all right so in short
right sizing recommendations help you to
save cost on your deployments improve
performance and what's most important
relieve you of the pain to make the
decision of what machine size do you
have there is no wrong decision even if
the machine size is not optimal
recommendations will detect that based
on the utilization they observe and
suggest you aside that it thinks
or might be a better fit so bring it all
together we have looked at how to deploy
application with the containers on
manage instance groups we've built
highly available and scalable stateless
applications on top of managed instance
groups and we have also looked at how to
apply right sizing recommendations to
your VMs and I want to leave you with
this that even if you have to deploy
your were close to virtual machines to
have the control full control over your
infrastructure you don't have to manage
everything by hand you can have highly
scalable and available deployments by
picking and choosing recommendations as
well as automated services such as auto
scaling onto healing auto updating that
work for you you are not on your own
thank you and just a quick reminder
don't forget to give the feedback on on
the session which is available in your
app all right all right thank you very
much
[Music]